He didn't believe me when I said it was really loud to do this:
Find a happy place, find a happy place, find a happy place!
Hey Peter,
So I saw a lot of comments about Sky Drawing
which is where you start up here and you
go down like that
it's actually the easiest way for me to aim,
but it's also bad form, cause it is technically unsafe
Because you're pointing your arrow up really high. Save the birds. Right.
Danger for clouds.
So I'm trying to get better at the -- like -- correct...
...way to draw.
The one benefit about doing it like that where you just look down the bow...
...is that you aim while you drawback
so that you release right away...
...and not be holding a shaky bow while you try to stabilize it.
I think the archery challenge is gonna be: you have 5 arrows, and there's 5 red circles...
...and see how many of those red circles you can hit with your 5 arrows.
Grand tournament will be held...
...upon release of our next video.
Our next Corridor video. Not our next samandniko video.
Almost missed.
Alright, so as you can see, Studio 5 is under construction.
In Studio 4, we thought it
was getting a little hot in there as well
We wanted to do some insulation
We wanted to do some insulation ourselves, and so the question is...
When we did this ceiling in here,
this whole studio was full of dust.
So, what do we do?
We gotta move all of our stuff over here
We gotta move all of our stuff over here for a few weeks.
You know, honestly I don't think it will be that bad, but I say that now
So, see Jake, your problem is,
is unlike us, you guys don't get desks that roll
I know
It would have been far easier if
you guys just had to roll everything
Yeah, I mean the biggest problem is Wren and Carmichael are both still working off of doors
(hearty chuckle)
So. Seal off the camera room
We're gonna have to seal off the back.
We're gonna have to move all the wardrobe
Move everything out of the upstairs kitchen,
cause it's all gonna get covered in dust
- What happens now?
- Teabag him!
(chanting) One of us. One of us. One of us...
Sam and Niko!
- Do I wanna go to China?
- I mean, yeah
My good friends at Aperture...
Aputure!
A cooler?
What's in this cooler?
Ooooooh
120 singles head.
Ah, Gold Mouth!
Yaaaaaaaay
- Look at how big the LED is.
- You've never seen the custom LED light I made...
...It's brighter than any LED you've ever seen
Pop in a battery, you can light up the whole street. I'm assuming that's the same light...
...so I'm not going to open that.
- This is a different box!
- I hope this is dishes
Please be a dish, please be a dish!
It's really heavy
A half? A half
And then...
Another lightstorm.
Oh sick
Cool, wow. So many lightstorms now
Ohhhh...
[sexy sax man theme]
[Background talking]